[Musique]
plan de mandature du conseil
départemental de la réunion 2021 2028 un
plan qui sera appelée à évoluer au fil
du temps pour s'adapter aux difficultés
aux contraintes chaque année la mise en
oeuvre du projet départemental sera
évaluée pour chacune des dix ambitions
sous la responsabilité des élus
concernés avec vous pour créer un vivre
ensemble qui favorise l'inclusion de
tous et de chacun
[Musique]
première ambition renforcer l'accès au
droit et à la prévention répondre à
l'urgence sociale enfin c'est l'accueil
de proximité sur les sites du
département l'amélioration de l'accès
aux services publics aide à
l'accomplissement des démarches
administratives maintien de l'aide
financière aux centres d'hébergement et
d'urgence pour les femmes avec enfants
notamment celles qui sont victimes de
violence met en place d'un plan
départemental de prévention nouvelles
aides et de nouveaux dispositifs pour
les bénéficiaires du rsa
deuxième ambition accompagner les
parents protéger les enfants et
favoriser leur réussite création d'un
site dédié à la parentalité dans chaque
canton renforcement de l'accompagnement
des parents pendant la grossesse et les
premières années de la vie de l'enfant
soutien aux porteurs de projets de garde
d'enfants mise en place de nouvelles
actions de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes recrutement
pluriannuel des assistantes familiales
troisième ambition protéger accompagner
les plus vulnérables soutien au maintien
à domicile des personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie favoriser un vieillissement
en bonne santé
structuration et professionnalisation de
l'aide à domicile renforcement du
soutien aux aidants faciliter l'accès à
la propriété augmentation du nombre de
réhabilitation de l'habitat création et
rénovation des états
avec vous pour amener toutes les
générations sur le chemin de leur
réussite 4e ambitions favoriser la
réussite des jeunes on faire des
citoyens soutien aux jeunes les plus
fragilisées prévenir le décrochage
scolaire coaching personnalisé aux
allocataires du rsa accompagnement
individualisé aux étudiants en mobilité
accompagnement des jeunes dans l'usagé
du numérique et aux risques liés à
internet
5e ambitions démocratiser la culture
valoriser le patrimoine promouvoir le
sport mais en homme plus chantier du
musée historique de l'habitation de l'
esclavage avis elle soutient la création
de supports d'appropriation du
patrimoine réhabilitation de lieux
historiques et patrimoniaux soutien aux
projets des artistes des associations
culturelles des lieux de culture dans le
domaine du sport augmentation du nombre
de clubs bénéficiaires de ces
subventions renforcement du soutien au
sport de haut niveau
avec vous pour créer une agriculture
locale est responsable pour l'avenir de
notre île 6e ambition accompagner la
réunion vers une agriculture durable
visant la souveraineté alimentaire
poursuite de la mise en oeuvre du plan
grippe et 2030 préservation du foncier
agricole produire plus et produire mieux
en soutenant la diversification végétale
et animale des exploitations faciliter
la transformation des produits locaux et
la commercialisation circuit co création
d'une main collectives territoriales au
bénéfice exclusif des produits agricoles
100% pays
[Musique]
à
avec vous pour agir durablement et
préserver notre île c'est hier ambition
faire de la roja duterde espace majeur
de l'aménagement de notre territoire
valoriser les territoires ruraux de
soutien aux communes sera également
conforté à travers le pacte de
solidarité
amélioration et développement du réseau
routier départemental
8e ambitions préserver et valoriser
durablement de ressources mise en place
d'un programme ambitieux de lutte contre
les espèces invasives et de reboisement
de l'île plantation d'un million d'ha
dans le milieu naturel et dans les
espaces publics urbains et périurbains
rénovation des réseaux d'eau potable et
réutilisation de l'eau de pluie soutien
au développement des productions bio
local et de l'agroforesterie
avec vous pour renforcer nos biens dans
l'océan indien 9e ambition développer
les échanges et la solidarité dans
l'océan indien soutient des programmes
visant à améliorer la sécurité
alimentaire et nutritionnelle de long
terme en india océanie en particulier à
madagascar et aux comores soutien aux
échanges d'expertisé réciproque à
l'échelle régionale et à la valorisation
des compétences réunionnaises
avec vous pour faciliter la vie de tous
les réunionnais et de chaque citoyen 10e
ambitions simplifier les démarches de
nos publics simplification des processus
et des procédures amélioration de
l'accueil et la modernisation du versant
des aides mises en oeuvre de l'open data
des solutions seront également
expérimenté pour mieux associer les
citoyens la construction des politiques
publiques départementales
[Musique]